gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france 24 en español estamos de regreso
para conocer las principales noticias en
materia económica junto a jorge hurtado
jorge bueno vamos a iniciar con lo que
revelaron las minutas de la última
reunión de la reserva federal de eeuu
así es ante vez que estas actas revelan
que la mayoría de los directores del
banco central de eeuu están de acuerdo
en realizar una acelerada subida de los
tipos de interés inclusive más alta que
la realizada en la última vez en 2015
aunque también la fed estima que las
perspectivas macroeconómicas en este año
son mucho mejores según ellos que las de
2015 porque el mercado laboral está más
fuerte el banco central señaló que la
vía apropiada para determinar la
política monetaria dependerá de cómo se
desarrollen los mercados y que se
actualizará su lectura de la situación
en cada reunión durante su última
reunión los tipos de interés quedaron en
un rango de entre 0% y 0 25% pero
adelantaron que la inflación la más alta
en 40 años provocaría una subida en
marzo los tipos de interés de eeuu son
la referencia mundial de los
y emitir cualquier tipo de préstamos
claro bueno porque seguimos hablando de
inflación pero vamos ahora hasta canadá
así es y es que ahí los precios al
consumidor aumentaron a su nivel
interanual más alto en 30 años la
inflación en canadá se aceleró en enero
este año al 5.5 por ciento en
comparación con 12 meses atrás es la
cifra más alta registrada de septiembre
de 1991 según los datos de estadística
nada la alta inflación fue motivada por
los altos precios de la vivienda que
aumentaron al 6,2 por ciento en enero en
términos interanuales así como los
precios de los alimentos que subieron un
5,7 por ciento esto por los problemas en
la cadena de suministros como por las
malas condiciones de los cultivos varios
analistas apuntan a que el aumento en
los precios de la energía el récord del
mercado inmobiliario canadiense y la
presión salarial harán que la inflación
siga en aumento recientemente el
gobernador del banco de canadá tiff
macklem ya dijo que los tipos de interés
tienen que subir para hacer frente a
esta elevada inflación porque vamos a
orar hasta áfrica occidental la región
está sufriendo una escasez de
combustible de verdad así es y bueno
nigeria que es la mayor economía de
áfrica sufre escasez de combustible
desde hace dos semanas y te cuento por
qué la falta de combustible provocó
largas filas en la gasolinera y ha
generado un incremento en los precios
del transporte la escasez comenzó
después de que se entregara gasolina
adulterada en las estaciones y generó el
caos en lagos y en la capital
administrativa aguja la empresa
petrolera estatal nigeriana aseguró que
espera sufrir con 2300 millones de
litros de gasolina de aquí a finales de
febrero la mayoría de los hogares
nigerianos usan gasolina y diésel para
alimentar sus generadores ya que el
suministro eléctrico público sufre
constantemente apagones el gobierno
culpó a 4 comercializadores de petróleo
del país por importar gasolina
adulterada adulterada y nigeria que es
el mayor productor de crudo de áfrica
depende de las importaciones de
combustibles para cumplir con la demanda
local esto porque sus cuatro refinerías
no funcionan o lo hacen por debajo de la
capacidad
vamos ahora con los indicadores de la
jornada
iniciamos con un wall street que cerró
mixto en una jornada volátil por la
publicación de las minutas de la reserva
federal de eeuu que como mencionamos
anteriormente revelan que la subida de
los tipos de interés será más rápido de
lo que se espera el dax 40 de fráncfort
cerró con una caída de un ser como 28
por ciento por el temor a la subida de
los tipos de interés en europa y la
bolsa de sao paulo en américa latina
cerró en verde y sumó su séptima subida
consecutiva con el dólar a la baja en
brasil para finalizar como siempre la
esperada cifra del día cuál es esta vez
la cifra del día es 2800 millones de
euros ese fue el comercio entre irlanda
e irlanda del norte tras el primer año
del brasil las cifras oficiales muestran
que las importaciones a irlanda desde
irlanda del norte aumentaron un 65 por
ciento hasta los 3.900 millones de euros
lo que supone 1.500 millones de euros
más en comparación con la cifra revelada
en 2020 jorge hurtado muchísimas gracias
por otra la completísima crónica hasta
aquí la información económica en france
24 en español los invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto la programación
y en france24 punto com
[Música]